the CBS News investigation finds we
could be carrying electronics that
contain the product of child labor
report by Amnesty International two
years ago first uncovered that children
were mining the mineral Cobalt in the
Democratic Republic of Congo or DRC as
it known it ended up in products from
dozens of companies including Apple
Microsoft Tesla and Samsung cobalt is
needed in batteries powering common
devices like our cell phones laptops and
in the growing number of electric cars
Debora patta travelled to the DRC to
follow the complex supply chain she
joins us from Johannesburg South Africa
with the story Deborah good morning good
morning the DRC is embroiled in conflict
and it's difficult and sometimes
dangerous to report from there on a
recent trip to the south of the country
we saw what looked like the Wild West
they're digging in trenches and laboring
in lakes hunting for treasure in a
playground from hell hard enough for an
adult man unthinkable for a child and
yet tens of thousands of Congolese kids
are involved in every stage of mining
for cobalt more than half the world's
supply comes from the DRC 20% of that is
mined by hand
we traveled along collapsing dirt roads
children are everywhere digging for
cobalt in abandoned open pit mines and
it's clear security officials in charge
here only some of them in uniform have
something to hide such sensitivity
around cobalt mine that every few
hundred feet we get stopped requesting
letters documents even though we have
official permission to be here but for
the Chinese middlemen we saw who buy the
cobalt there are no such constraints
they have free access to the mines
inside women and children are doing
so-called artisanal mining but don't be
fooled this is no quaint cottage
industry at barely ten years old
children lug heavy
acts of cobalt to be washed in rivers
from as early as 4:00 they can pick it
out of a pile and even those too young
to work spend much of the day breathing
in toxic fumes the officials deny that
there's child labor clearly it's obvious
that there is but whenever a camera or
security person or policeman appears
then the children are chased away
Ziqi Swasey is 11 years old and agreed
to meet us outside the mine why aren't
you in school myself my parents are dead
he said and I stay with my grandma so
you need to make money for your granny
we ask these companies whether child
mined cobalt is being used in their
products all acknowledged problems with
the supply chain but say they require
their suppliers to follow responsible
sourcing guidelines Apple said it leads
the industry in supply chain standards
and last year cut ties with the largest
artisanal cobalt supplier Microsoft told
us and does not tolerate child labor and
that they are working with NGOs to
eliminate it samsung said it's mapping
its supply chain and Tesla explained it
performs audits and has very little
cobalt in its batteries but our
investigation shows just how complicated
it is to trace child mined cobalt in the
global supply chain we followed the
mineral as it left the mines piled high
on every mode of transport available
sacks were already mixed up without
labels making it impossible to know who
had mined them the children's cobalt is
brought here to this market where it is
bought by a Chinese company for
extremely low prices we wanted to see
whether there was any attempt to check
if the cobalt had been mined by children
so our team went back later with a
hidden camera when we offered to sell a
truckload of cobalt nobody asked us who
mined the mineral only what the quality
was this man told us that the Chinese
traders here bought all the cobalt and
sold it mainly to one Chinese company
Congo Dongfang miny
known locally as C DM C DM is owned by
global Chinese giant y-you but y-you
said they stopped buying from that
market last year and have put in place a
detailed program to eliminate child
labor from their supply chain and yet in
this murky process of sourcing Cobalt
one thing is clear children are still
here carrying the weight of our
high-tech world on their shoulders
we spoke to eight major tech companies
who've been linked to the supply chain
and while some of them have joined
initiatives to solve this problem we saw
very little evidence that the mines we
visited of anyone actually helping these
children packed an NGO working with
Apple Microsoft and why you described
support from these companies as a drop
in the ocean compared to the dozens of
companies still buying child mined
Cobalt Gail all right Deborah pattern
reporting from Johannesburg now that
we've seen the video you can't act like
you can't see it so I would think tech
companies have some rethinking to do in
consumers is something we need to think
about as well definitely kids working
there you can say you have policies in
place but if they're not being enforced
that doesn't do it exactly right we're
gonna stay on the story too yes we are
you can see longer responses from
companies on our website CBS s Morning
Calm and tomorrow we'll share more from
the story of Zeki that's a little boy
that Deborah spoke with Plus how
missionaries are working to get children
out of those mines